how about this for an introduction like
LeBron James he is the pride of Akron
Ohio Wow how about that I love that why
not they got the same amount of
championship he's a head coach of the
Tennessee Titans Mike Vrabel back here
on the program how are you coach great
guys I did not put that in any bio so no
you're on Bing
no you're by noise you're from Akron
Ohio and you know yeah but yeah you
added the LeBron James also could you be
any less excited about after the break
we'll do a mic rainbow-like that was
about it
solid coach you know you know how a
compliment coming from you
as a coach to your players that if it
comes from you it's got to mean
something right you don't just write you
come from the Belichick coaching world
in a way I mean right you you coach by
this guy if this guy compliments you
that's got to stand out so you were just
throw you throw those around probably
like manhole covers if you call somebody
solid what does that mean that's good
Southall it is good it is yeah I would
say that solid is uh fair to upper
Midland I mean it's uh it's above
average and put then again like there's
no guys on our team that when I asked
him are you doing J on a jam from
California he'll be like solid and have
this like smile on his face I think
solid somehow is actually pretty good
because I'm like what did that mean
Jenner that mean like good or better
than good he's like no I'm doing I'm
doing great he's like I'm doing solid
I'm like okay like okay so that's now
being used you say as a shorthand of
everything's cool everything's cool
that's what I've learned in the last
year I was out here you're put you're
more plugged into the youth of America's
basically what you're telling me right
now because because because I'm trying
to you know like do me a solid you know
that's that's that that's my era so I
guess that would be a positive but yeah
that that's the that's the conversation
that we have here from time to time is
like the the meaning of the word solid
sometimes I get a little bit hanky about
that you know what I don't seem to be it
seems to be a little
older show so got to come back into the
tire go that's a solid compliment from
you my Greville it's a solid compliment
hey and you know it's it's a very an art
very an arborist see now he went there I
was trying to avoid this for obvious
reasons but you know I don't want to get
into a too deep but you do have your
left tackle very important part of this
offensive football team right I mean how
important is tango coach yep right on
the coach and he's a great effort and
finished off the year playing very well
so that's the expectations so so you
hand you hand that very important part
of your program off to a Michigan man
and who through all those touchdowns to
you in Super Bowl championships that's
the ultimate Tom Brady has given us the
ultimate retort he really has when it
all comes down to tell Tom I said I
always wanted a sack you're in college
but you never played enough to actually
how does how did he respond to that Mike
oh you can imagine Mike Vrabel here on
the Rich Eisen show okay so let's so
let's get into your world now what it's
filled with zoom meetings bill but
that's or Microsoft rooms or what I'm I
don't know what the it's probably zooms
probably the one we settled on and again
I think we've handled the distraction of
the virtual offseason program very well
we're finishing up this week our third
week and have not done any team meetings
with our with our current veteran team
I've done it with the rookies but it was
really an idea of focused on the
individual learning a lot of these guys
to be in there for for less than an hour
and a half to not wear them out to make
sure that they're engaged and that that
our coaches are giving these
the details they need to improve and
install some of the stuff that maybe is
a little different than what we did last
year so where do you stand on the
concept of rookies because we don't know
you know what we don't know and what
we're assuming is you're not going to be
able to get much practice time
physically with these guys so are you
are you assessing them differently this
year Mike maybe than in previous years
well I mean I think the assessment has
to occur on the field but how well they
process information and in a short
amount of time what they can handle
always dictates what we give them they
have a little different rules as far as
how long they can meet and so we meet
with them a little extra and then we you
know we have a player engagement rookie
development program at 3:15 that they
are involved with to help them
transition into the NFL that we would
normally do if they were in our building
and so I would say that it's a it's been
a really good rookie class just from
from what I've been able to evaluate in
the meetings and kind of popping around
the different meeting rooms and asking
questions and and these guys seem to be
pretty engaged well in terms of coaching
philosophies I think you know
everybody's got different ones but the
ultimate one that you could run as a
straight line through every single coach
is you can only control what you can
control I know it's a cliche but you're
we're in the most uncontrolled situation
right now there's everything is outside
of your control
I mean I had Dave Roberts of the Dodgers
on yesterday Brian Kelly of Notre Dame
earlier I had Dan Quinn now I've got you
on and so many people look at you as a
head coach is like maybe you just need
to cure the situation or at least you
know the answer right yeah and I try to
inform our team this is a this is very
sensitive it's very serious and whatever
they tell us what we'll do we'll keep
moving forward I'll keep planning and
what they tell me
and that's to continue the virtual
program until May 29th I set out the
training camp schedule as if things are
full steam ahead with the rookies and
when they report and the veterans and
schedule and the days off but when they
say that that's going to change
then we'll adjust accordingly we can't
we can't eliminate distractions and
everything that we do we can only handle
them and I feel like our team
understands that and embraces that and
appreciate that yeah
how often though do you ask questions
about getting more clarity how often do
you ask the questions that I get asked
by fans or I ask people from your
position you know I don't I don't go
that far up the tree
I ask questions about hey what are we
allowed to do what our world of what's
within the rules tell me what the rules
are and then you know here's how we're
going to you know go about our business
as far as the training camp and the
times and things with the new CDA things
that might have changed a new
acclimation period all those types of
things are the things that concern me
not about where or when training camp
may start what does it give you schedule
there's 16 of them we got eight home I
can't accept that answer I'm sorry
that's answer we better not get off to
start we get off to last year you know
we're gonna have to we're gonna have to
get off to a better start and you know
we've we've said this we've got to start
hosting some of these playoff games the
formula for for winning championships
isn't to go on the road in January and
that's that's really the reality the
numbers will tell you that and so you
just have to have to play better and
obviously the season starts in after
Thanksgiving truly when teams start
going in different directions so that's
kind of a schedule yeah visit to Lambeau
Field two days after Christmas on a
Sunday night game what's the coldest
game you ever played in Mike that would
have been the Tennessee at new england
playoff game i forget the year maybe oh
three something like that it was so cold
that you know my buddies were like we'd
open a beer and if you didn't drink it
within a certain amount of time people
just turn it over it's frozen inside of
your face mask when you would breathe it
would crystallize on the inside from
from the
and then it would freeze it was it was
cold I mean it was around here oh I
think it the kickoff was a night game is
that what is that a game where Belichick
would wear the headband sort of like the
old you know the old days I don't know I
I don't know if he went with the
Jazzercise headband or not I can't
support the fall on that particular
night what what bill was wearing oh yeah
but you can send you can write you can
as a coach send a message on how you
dress right Mike you can do that right
where you do you dress like I don't care
out what the temperature is I'm out uh
and I'm you're sending a message to your
team before they go out there for
something like that you know I don't
know I mean I pretty much assume I'm am
pretty much with the with the vest
anyway so it's gonna mean it'll have a
vest on there somehow something like but
no I don't know but the sending a
message is just making sure get prepared
and that they're they're ready to go
that's that's what the message is what
about the same snow game was that not
not that cold up and doing one that
night it wasn't I mean it was just it
was just so much snow it qualified as a
blizzard because of it the wind's
earlier and the amount of snow and a
certain amount of time but I don't
remember that one being cold that was
just so much snow that they had snow
from one row piled on top of the other
so people and they were only going to
sit every other row but people said
screw that and they went they sat in
their season tickets but they were
sitting on like a three-foot snowdrift
because the snow had covered their seats
they didn't have enough time to get the
snow out of it so they just cleared
every other row and just dumped the snow
onto the row in between and that was cry
mean I had guys were having snow plows
come and take us to the stadium and all
kind of stall oh man I remember that day
and it's funny we had a Raider fan from
Boston calling the other day refer to it
as a snow game and I gave him crap I
said he's got to refer to as a tuck roll
game you know that's right yeah that's
that's probably for them that's not so
you refer to as the snow game from back
in the day and hey did you hear Richard
Seymour got named as the into the
Patriots Hall of Fame did I did I happen
to hear that I lost for the fifth
consecutive year what's up with that
though you know
you know I got plenty news and Stacy
James the director media and PR they're
right they used to call me every year
and for four straight years you caught
Mike you didn't get in you got beat out
followed by well why do you think that
is Mike just take a stand pretty much
just assume that a Mike might know he's
not getting in so why bother calling
them again but it's about your Patriot
career Mike you'd think that fans would
be able to separate Mike Vrabel the
championship Patriot from a coach whose
team ended the Brady Belichick error
every person in that Hall of Fame is
more than deserving and it's it's busy
and it's crowded and it's supposed to be
hard to get into that's why their Hall
of Fame's and if it's meant to be it'll
happen if not I'm gonna keep coaching
and living my life and then keep
enjoying my former teammates you know if
I had to term that answer you know what
I would term it solid solid yes sir
that was a solid answer Mike Vrabel that
was solid it's true well I hope
everything's solid in your world sir
I appreciate the call thanks again thank
you right guys that's Mike Vrabel right
here hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here